Drive by day Joe Rogan podcast by night,
all day.
That's the other thing.
Guy Mma in combat sports.
The means the use of social media total.
Really good.
So cool man.
Unless you're,
unless you're Ronda Rousey's Nunez fight are
so many fucking people.
You know what those mean?
What do you think she's coming back?
No,
I don't think she is.
I mean I don't think,
I don't think,
well if she does,
she should come back in a calculated manner.
Like don't just rush in and fight for the title like she did.
I think that's crazy.
Taking a year off,
getting head kick,
knocked out,
you know?
Where's your head out?
And was she 100% committed to this as far as like training for the entire time
off or did she just get in really good shape over the last few months and had
she been training at all before then?
I mean,
you'd have to ask her and answer all those questions,
but if she doesn't want to be fighting,
she shouldn't be fighting,
you know?
But you don't shouting from the beginning.
He had movement head movement,
so I assumed they worked on the hip movement.
I just think depression,
the way she comes to the angry face and all that shuts her down and,
and you know it's too much pressure.
A whole Hollywood career writes on it.
I mean that's not going to happen now.
Right,
right.
I mean because buddy the road too,
we talked about no footwork.
No,
but that's what nurses can do to you.
I would,
I like to see a Rhonda with a smile on her face.
Go to the ring,
being relaxed and calm,
send her away,
go to a Duane Ludwig for a year and have some smokers because you can still
legally do that.
And other clubs just striking,
you know,
she's just get in that moment that to see where your wet.
I think in training,
this is the problem that everybody has.
You know,
in training you always do good.
A lot of guys do good.
But you know as well as I do,
there's these gym guys are really good in training.
They can do it on a pressure.
So if she's been boxing and working on a striking and she's been hitting people
left,
they're right there.
They got some good people coming in.
I heard that she,
that works out to eva with Exa boxing champions or jammies and doing well
against them.
But then again,
you know that that's a nice safe environment,
bringing it under pressure with all the crap she had on her shoulders.
The is also a notation of the way Nunez is a very dangerous punch sought in
Strikeforce men right away,
right away her kicks or punches.
She kicks and punches so fucking hard and she has long arms and she puts you on
the end of these long punches and cheat.
Dinged Rhonda very early in the fight and you could tell she was rock.
She goes right back into the home fight.
That's right.
Thank habitat and noon is also leans all the way over.
So it's hard to take her down,
you know,
and run the show you,
they'll show,
you know,
maybe she's doing it.
I'm just saying what I don't see,
you know,
maybe start wrestling over as well tell because a girl like that with so much
talent,
she'll pick that up so fast.
But if she suddenly shoots for a singer or,
but
you'd already been rocked.
So I think that because remember she shucked her off early clenches always upper
body couch and she always reaches him with the left arm.
You know Greg Jackson,
I talked about it after the Holm fight that day had seen every single one of her
fights.
She comes at you,
she grew up that left arm extended,
tries to get ahold of girls with the left arm,
hip tosses them,
gets them on the ground,
armbars him and they just were so prepared.
What is it that was going to say?
Interesting that whole shift from MMA,
from boxing demo may just trained for Ronda Rousey fight.
Cordy car brand members says a kickbox kickboxing and boxing champ.
But I'm saying in terms of her,
Emma May prep,
the goal was Ronda Rousey,
right.
And now with Cody Garbrandt he talked about in high school,
Dominick Cruz.
And you think you wonder,
well,
the,
the laser focus,
right?
The television,
obviously you have to work on everything,
but if that's your target and you see what he did to cruise,
I,
it's,
well,
there's a lot of fighters.
Okay.